سجل تضخمه في السعوديه في ابريل الماضي
استقرارا وذلك للشهر الثاني على التوالي
عند اثنين وسبعه اعشار في المئه ومنخفضا
عند مستويات يناير الماضي والتي بلغت
ثلاثه واربعه اعشار في المئه اي بانخفاض
بلغ سبعه اعشار في المئه التضخم في ابريل
من عام 20 ثلاثه وعشرين سجل ارتفاعا طفيفا
عند مقارنته بنفس الشهر من العام الماضي
حيث جاء هذا ارتفاع مشاهدينا مدعوما بشكل
اساسي بارتفاع اسعار السكن والكهرباء
والماء والغاز بنسبه ثمانيه وعشرين في
المئه بالاضافه لارتفاع اسعار الاغذيه
والمشروبات بنسبه واحد في المئه لنرى الان
مشاهدينا بالارقام كيف اثرت اسعار
الايجارات على التضخم في شهر ابريل عام 23
مقارنه بشهر ابريل من العام الماضي فكما
نرى هنا ارتفعت الايجارات الفعليه للمساكن
بنسبه 9.6 في شهر اب من العام الحالي جاء
هذا ارتفاع مشاهدينا مدعوما بزياده اسعار
جرارات الشقق بنسبه 22 وعشرين في المئه
واسعار الاغذيه والمشروبات هي الاخرى سجلت
ارتفاعا بنسبه واحد في المئه كما سجل قسم
النقل ارتفاعا بلغ تثبته مشاهدينا واحدا
وعشرا في المئه وذلك مقارنه بشهر ابريل من
العام الماضي سجل قسم المطاعم والفنادق
ارتفاعا بنسبه سته اعشار وعشرين في المئه
اما قسم التعليم فقد سجل ارتفاعا بنسبه
ثلاثه في المئه لنرى الان كيف ارتفعت
اسعار المستهلك في شهر ابريل من العام
الحالي مقارنه بشاي مارس الماضي سجل مؤشر
اسعار مستهلك ارتفاعا طفيفا في شهر ابريل
من عام 20 23 بالنسبه 4 اعشار في المئه
مقارنه بشهر مارس من النفس العام جاء هذا
مشاهدينا مدعوما بارتفاع الايجارات
الفعليه للمساكن بنسبه سته اعشار في المئه
واسعار الاغذيه والمشروبات التي بنسبه
اربعه في المئه وقسم الترفيه والثقافه
بنسبه 82
ياتي هذا بعد او ياتي بعد ذلك مشاهدينا
القسم السلع والخدمات الشخصيه المتنوعه
التي ارتفعت هي الاخرى بنسبه اربعه اعشار
في المئه وقسم ملابس ارتفع بنسبه ثمانيه
اعشار في المئه واذا نظرنا مشاهدينا لنسبه
التضخم في السعوديه شهريا منذ ابريل
الماضي نجد ان معي الماضي كان الاقل خلال
12 شهرا الماضيه عند اثنين وعشرين في
المئه فيما سجل الاعلى في يناير الماضي
عند 43
فيما كان معدل تضخم فوق ثلاثه في المئه
خلال الاشهر الخمسه الاخيره منذ العام
الماضي عدا نوفمبر الذي سجل 62%
من الرياض بدايه كيف تقرا هذه الارقام
للتضخم في السعوديه الشهر الماضي
والاسباب الارتفاع هي مقنعه اهلا خلاف
بالساده المشاهدين انا اعتقد بانه اذا
تتبعنا من بدايه السنه 2020 23 ولاحظ بان
كان مرتفع 3.4 بعد ذلك نزل الى ثلاثه في
المئه الان نتحدث في مارس كان اثنين فاصله
سبعه الان اثنين فاصله سبعه يعتبر مستقر
لهذا الشهر شهرين على التوالي لذلك انا
اعتقد اذا لاحظنا حديث وزير الماليه في
وقت سابق يتحدث بان المستهدفات لنسبه
التضخم في العام 2020 هي ما بين اثنين ونص
الى اثنين فاصله سته لذلك انا استطيع ان
اقول بانه ضمن المستهدفات التي تنتهجها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واذا نظرنا على
مستوى العالمي اذا هو يظل ضمنا اقل
المستويات عالميا اذا ما قارنا المملكه
بمجموعه لذلك انا اعتقد هو ما زال تحت
السي وارقام انا اعتقد يعني ضمن
المستهدفات اثنين الى ثلاثه في المئه كثير
هو يعني مستهدفات لكثير من ارتفاع اسعار
الايجارات المساكن انخفاضها دائما هو
الترمومتر
الانخفاض او الارتفاع لماذا هل هذا مبرر
اصلا هل ربطها في التضخم ووجودها ضمن احد
العوامل التي تحدد ارتفاع نسبه التضخم او
انخفاضها هل هو صحيح برايك سؤال مهم
واستراتيجي اليوم اذا شاهدنا بان تقريبا
25.2% هي من سله التضخم هي تذهب الى
العقار تذهب الى الكهرباء تذهب الى الماء
والغاز الا يعتقد هي نسبه كبيره ولكن في
وجهه نظري على الاقل اتمنى بما ان ما يحرك
هذه النسبه هبوطا وصعودا هو العقار او هي
الايجارات الشقق انا اتمنى بانها تفرد
بنسبه مئويه منفصله عن الكتالوري ز او عن
المؤشر ليكن الكهرباء والماء والغاز عباره
عن صنف وياتي العقار مثلا والشقق او ما له
علاقه بالجانب العقاري يعني مثلا لو فصلت
انا اعتقد يعطي صوره اكبر واشمل يعطي صناع
القرار ما هي المؤشرات التي ادت الى رفع
هذا المؤشر ما هي الاسباب التي ادت الى
هبوطه حتى معالجه مثل هذه الامور انا
اعتقد بانها ترسم صوره اقتصاديه واضحه
لاحدى المؤشرات التي نلاحظ وخاصه في
الفتره الاخيره يعتبر محرك مهم لنسبه
التضخم صعودا وهبوطا ممتاز
التضخم لم يتراجع حتى الان حتى مع رفع
النسب الفائده من قبل الفدراري الامريكي
وهذه السياسات النقديه المتشدده وايضا حتى
اللي تبع فيها
البنك المركزي السعودي هل نعز هذا لانه
هذا الرفع في نسبه الفائده لم يستطع مثلا
السيطره على التضخم او انخفاض هذه النسبه
ام لانه احنا اصلا ما وصلنا لمراحل متقدمه
في التضخم مثل ما حدث في اوروبا في امريكا
في غيرها وبالتالي هذه السياسات النقديه
لا تؤثر بشكل مباشر على نسب التضخم لدينا
نعم طبعا لابد تفرق ما بين الهياكل
الاقتصاديه للدول المتقدمه والدول الناشئه
والدول الناميه مثلا الهيكل الاقتصادي
للولايات المتحده الامريكي هو مختلف عن
الهيكل الاقتصادي في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مثلا نحن تلعب الايرادات النفطيه
دور مهم والان بصدد الايرادات غير النفطيه
ولكن في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الايرادات هي كلها قادمه من الضرائب بشكل
اكبر لذلك انا اعتقد بان بحكم ربط الريال
بالدولار فنحن نتبع سياسه الفدرالي من
ناحيه السياسات الماليه مساحه السياسات
النقديه سواء تشدديه او توسعيه وبما ان
الفيدرالي يرفع نسب الفائده هذا اقتصاديا
يطلق عليه سياسه نقديه تشدديه ولكن
السؤال المهم لماذا نرفع على الرغوه بان
معدلات التضخم عندنا ضمن النطاق المستهدف
لماذا نرفع والمعدلات التضخم جيده لدينا
لا نستطيع حقيقه الا الرفع بخلاف هذا
الامر فان كثير من الاستثمارات او او من
الاموال ستخرج من الاقتصاد لتذهب تبحث عن
نسب الفائده المرتفعه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك نحن نرفع من اجل هذا السبب
ولكن تقوم المملكه لعمل توازن تذهب الى
سياسات ماليه توسعيه للخلق توازن ما بين
هذا التشدد وهذا الانفتاح وهذا خلق لدينا
حقيقه هذا النوع من التوازن وانا بحقيقه
اؤكد لك بان السياسات ما تقوم بها وزاره
الماليه
والبنك المركزي السعودي هو عمل عظيم جبار
خلق هذه الخلطه من التوازن بان يكون
معدلات التضخم ضمن المستهدفه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر كان معي هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
الاقتصادي الدكتور علي الحازمي شكرا يا
دكتور
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات